des immeubles bombardés sans relâche
marioupol pilonné sans retenue
par les forces russes
explosion sourde sur le port à ce sujet
les soldats se mettent à l'abri
les ambulanciers ne peuvent plus
travailler
et un l'hôpital il faut soigner dans
l'urgence
dans ce couloir une femme dévastée l'un
de ses enfants a été tué dans le
bombardement qu'elle vient de vivre où
nous sommes allés chez mon frère les
femmes et les enfants sont allés dans
les sous-sols et ensuite des obus de
mortier ont atteint l'immeuble on était
piégé au sous sol et deux enfants sont
morts personne n'a pu les sauver des
habitants privés d'eau de gaz
d'électricité de nourriture situation
insoutenable dramatique selon un élu de
la mairie
il y à de nombreux cadavres dans les
rues il est impossible de les enlever à
cause des bombardements incessants
nous ne savons pas combien de gens se
terrent dans les abris et combien sont
morts ou blessés sous les décombres
are you ball sombrant chaque jour un peu
plus dans les ténèbres de la guerre